Uh, so we were talking
about green chemistry. Uh,
today we'll talk about
one aspect of Mitsui,
Nobu reaction and then get on to acids
and acid derivatives. And then, uh,
we'll do that again next, uh,
lecture more about acid derivatives,
condensations and some
stuff about carbohydrates.
And then the last two lectures,
uh,
now I remember when we were
talking about green chemistry,
they were some new
processes that were desired.
There were old processes
that that need improvement,
a new process that processes that need
to be developed according to these,
uh, the wishes of the
pharmaceutical industry. Uh,
remember there were six votes for aromatic
cross coupling I mentioned right at
the end last time.
That's how to put to benzene rings or
other aromatic rings together without
using Hallo aromatics. We haven't
talked about those reactions, but uh,
but that's their top desire then how to
use aldehydes or ketones plus ammonia
and reduction to give a chiral mean.
Now notice how many of these things
have to do with getting a single lead
antitumor because that's so important
in drugs to have a single in antivirus.
And this notice what they want
here is to do what nature does.
We've talked before about making
glutamic acid by what's called reductive
Amination, where you have
a reducing agent, Nadh,
you make the amine and
then and then reduce it.
So they would like to be
four of the pharmaceutical
six pharmaceutical companies
said that was something they would really
like to be able to do or asymmetric
hydrogenation of Olefins
and ina means or it means,
and notice this is hydrogenation of
an IA mean this very reaction here,
but what they want is asymmetric.
That his ability to make a
single [inaudible] ante mercy.
You don't have to throw half the
stuff away and do a separation. Uh,
four voted for a greener
Fluor nation method.
A lot of drugs have fluorine in them.
And the reagents that put those
in are often pretty vigorous ones.
Uh, nitrogen chemistry,
avoiding a zip codes and three,
avoiding hydrazine, which
is very poisonous. Uh,
asymmetric Hydra amination.
Again, asymmetric,
a greener electrophilic nitration we
talked about a electrophilic aromatic
substitution nitration uh, but what
they want is a greener way to do it.
And the final one is asymmetric
addition of HCN. Notice incidentally,
that four of these,
uh,
eight half of them have to do
with asymmetric a synthesis,
making chiral things. And notice
that s a f, uh, six of them,
six of the eight have to do
with nitrogen. Okay. Now,
uh, at the end last time we were
talking about that the other table,
the one of processes that need improving,
and in particular something that seems
surprising to many chemists is oh,
activation for nuclear
fillic substitution. We've
talked about that so long,
getting, getting a halogen or
a Tassel, eight that can, uh,
that can be substituted. But this is, they
want something that's better than that.
And notice that three voted for a safer
and more environmental Mitsui Nobu
reaction. So let's see what
the Mitsui Nobu reaction is,
and you'll see that it is a type
of height of, of that second case,
a activation of, Ooh, for
nuclear affiliate substitution.
So there's a picture of a Mitsui,
Nobu, and he, uh, in the 1960s,
he invented this reaction with
a great leaving group, uh,
the o p plus fennel three leaving group.
And so if you bring in a nucleophile
Bingo, it, it's a very clean,
a substitution reaction that is clean
in the sense that it gives a high yield.
Uh, so, and it's very
general, the nucleophile, uh,
any nucleophile we'll work,
it seems if it has a PKA,
if it's more acidic than
15, for example, a carb,
oxalate can get an r put audit
or the phosphoric acid or,
or the, uh, emitted,
or in three minus or most significantly
active methylene compounds.
So let's see what that means.
Active methylene compound.
Okay.
So here's a specific example taken from
Mitson Ho Booze Paper in the journal
synthesis to make s minus
methyl succinic acid.
So it's an asymmetric synthesis to make a,
and it starts with a,
with a chiral starting material,
s minus ethyl lactate.
So the idea is to make the Oah
into a leaving group. So let's see.
Let's read through his thing
and see how he does it.
He uses the reagents one and two.
Now,
one is try fennel phosphene.
And two is a compound
whose acronym is d a d.
And we'll see later what it's
die. Ethel, a Zodiac carb oxalate.
So we'll see how that works. But at any
rate, those two in the next slide, but,
but uh, for now, let's just take that,
that makes that leaving group the, uh,
puts the foss try phosphorus on
the oxygen and with a plus charge.
So now we got a good leaving group and
we want a nucleophile to displace it.
And the nucleophile they use in this
example is Ethel Cyan. No acetate.
Okay. So, uh, so it's,
it's the ethyl Ester of a Siddique acid,
but the carbon has a cyan on it and that
makes it an active methylene compound.
Okay. And the reason is
it has a pka of 13. It's,
it's pretty acidic for a ch bond.
Now the reason of course is what you
get is an email late because there's an
Alpha carbon eel.
It's Alpha to a carbon steel,
but it's also alpha to the CN
triple bond. So it's doubly, uh,
activated by low lumos next door.
So easily makes that an eye.
So this,
this then is can be a nucleophile
that will displace on the carbon.
So it's gonna come across and,
and invert the carbon. Okay.
And make the new bond.
And that's, that's uh,
the first product they want Diane Ethel
to Cyanna three methyls succinate.
Now notice they say the
yield is pretty good,
61% right.
And notice especially that
the conditions are very mild.
These reactions are started at minus
20 degrees and then just warm to room
temperature. It's not something that
needs a lot of heating. On the other hand,
they had to isolate it by preparative
layer chromatography. So that's,
that's not an easy way,
an easy thing to do on a largish scale.
So that's certainly a painful thing
to do to try to get written what this,
this is, it tends to be insoluble
so you can filter it off.
But to get the last bits of it out,
you have to do this layer chromatography.
So that's certainly not so great. Uh, uh,
notice that it says ultimately the
optical purity is greater than 99%.
Right now this reaction is indeed very,
very clean in version.
So that's one of the hallmarks
of the Mitsui Nobu reaction.
But in fact it's not proved by this,
that 99% purity because you notice at
the end it was really crystallized.
The product has recrystallized.
So even if there was a little bit
of the wrong Ian antitumor in there,
when you crystallize it,
you'd get only the writing antitumor
right in purifying it that way.
So this doesn't prove it,
but it's true that it gives very,
very clean and version. And that's
one of its main advantages. Okay.
But notice incidentally that this,
that this isn't the product they wanted.
This is an intermediate, right?
And notice that there would be,
there's two,
there are two chiral centers,
this one which was 99%
inverted and this one, uh,
which came from the anti and that,
that did the attacking the
active methylene compound.
And there's no reason that
that should be only one, right?
It could have inverted at the stage of
the [inaudible] that is the anti and
would've been planar because of the
conjugation with the, with the, uh,
double bonds next door.
So a,
wouldn't that lower the yield?
No,
because of the product they're finally
going to, and you'll see how that is.
They hydrolyze this intermediate
to s meinl methyl succinic acid,
which you'll notice is what it is
they're trying to make up at the top.
So they were able to convert
the ester to an acid,
the other Esther to an acid by,
that's a fee,
the reverse of a Fischer esterification
acid and water and the CN triple bond
also hydrolyzes to an acid,
although it takes more work,
it was heated under reflux for 16 hours,
but that converted that one to an acid.
And now you notice this,
this carbon isn't chiral anymore
because it's got to acid groups.
And even more than that, it turns out
that when you have a situation like that,
it decarboxylates,
it loses the Sio two.
And the h comes on here. So
again, it's not a chiral carbons.
So this is the product and
the ultimate yield was,
was 29% overall. Right? So, uh,
that's not a hundred percent reaction,
but it's very, very clean in terms of the,
of the product being stereo,
chemically pure. Okay.
And this,
the purity,
the stereo chemical purity version is
sometimes used by synthetic chemist when
they design a complicated
synthesis and they make an alcohol,
but it turns out not to be the one
they want, right? It's the wrong iin.
Antitumor so then they use a version
of this reaction called the Mitsui,
Nobu inversion.
So for example,
suppose they've made this
s configured alcohol,
but what they really wanted was the are,
so what you need to do is make that Ooh
into Alevi group and bring an oxygen in
from the backside to make the other one.
So they can do this to correct the
synthetic mistake by using these,
uh, these reagents, a
trifle, fos feed and dad,
and a Siddique acid. So the acetic acid
is something that's more acidic than,
than a PKA, uh, uh, 13, 15.
It's got PKA five. So it'll do the
trick. So you mix these things together,
do the reaction,
and it makes the acetate in the back.
And now that's the ester
the alcohol you want.
So all you have to do is treat it with
acid and get the inverted alcohol.
Now how does this activation work?
How do you do this in order to get
the great leaving group? Uh, well,
you react, try fennel,
phosphene with HR to do that,
but they won't interact directly.
That's notice minus three.
And in the product it's minus one.
So you're going to need an oxidizing
agent in order to do their,
and that oxidizing agent is this
compound number one up here,
Die Ethel.
So it's an ethyl ester on both ends.
Notice it's symmetrical Aso,
Die Carb, oxalate, d, e a.
D. Now this is sort of a
complicated, uh, scheme,
uh, and it's, it's balanced
just right. So the right,
the correct nucleophile
will attack at each step.
There are three nuclear files
that are involved. There's the,
the phosphorus unshared
pair. There's the, uh,
unshared pair on an oxygen to the alcohol
and there's x minus that was formed
from the,
from the acid that you put in,
which is ultimately the thing
that's going to do the displacing.
That's the nucleophile that comes in.
So you don't want the wrong nucleophile
to be operating at any given time.
Okay. So first the unshared
pair on phosphorus attacks,
the double bond on nitrogen, which we'll
put a charge on this nitrogen here,
that when these electrons go on there,
what's good about having
the charge on that nitrogen?
Why would that be better than an ad
into any old, uh, and double bond?
And
it's got the,
the residents with the carbon eel.
So it's gonna,
it's gonna make this a little lake
system here. Okay? So that, that,
uh,
that comes in and now this HX is one of
these things that has a pka less than
15. So it's able then to, uh,
to protonate this, this, this, uh,
remember this is a fairly stable and iron,
but it's not as stable as x minus.
It doesn't have that lower PKA.
So this one's able to
protonate here. Now, uh,
notice if x attacked people.
If x attack x is a pretty good,
is the anti and have a pretty good acid.
You could imagine it attacking
the phosphorus to make a
fifth bond to phosphorus,
right? Phosphorus has vacant
d orbitals but if it did,
it would come off again because
it's a much better and I,
and then the anti and for the Forbes,
if you broke the
phosphorous nitrogen bond,
so this is the example of it being
tuned just right. So it could, uh, if,
if the x k Bonne it would just come off
again. But if the double bond, if the,
if the unshared pair of oxygen goes on,
then you'd get,
uh, the bond formed like this. Right?
And now that would come off
again, this, this is, uh,
the protonated oxygen is
a stronger acid than the,
than this would be,
but if it loses the proton,
right.
Okay,
then this one is now a better leaving
group, especially if it gets protonated.
Right? So now we can, now we've
made this thing here. Okay.
The, the, the made the oxygen
into a leaving group and now,
and notice that the same time this,
the nitrogen nitrogen,
which originally was a double
bond now has two hydrogens on it.
So it got reduced, right?
And that, and that is,
it was the oxidizing agent that
allowed this to happen. Okay.
And now x minus is able to do the nuclear
Phillips substitution and that's how
the Mitson Obu react,
activation happens.
And notice that this,
this last one here then is irreversible.
Once you put the x on,
this is not a good nucleophile,
it's not going to come back on.
So this is a high yield
process when you do that one.
Okay.
But the problem is that a complete
required chromatography that was bad about
it, then at least this aspect
of it has been improved.
And it's an interesting way in which
it's been proved. Instead of using,
try fennel phosphene the benzene
rings of the trifle Phosphene,
some of them are attached to
a polymer, right? Like that.
So that means if you have a polymer
bead that holds this reagent, yeah.
At the end,
you don't have to do the chromatography
in order to separate your product from
the trifle phosphine oxide,
you just have to filter it because
it's attached to a solid polymer.
Okay.
But what,
what disturbs the green chemists about
this otherwise handy reaction is that
your goal is to eliminate
water between Hx and Roa H.
Right? But, uh, but in order to do that,
you generate byproducts that
have a molecular way to 450.
So this is what's called Adam inefficient.
You generate lots of waste for all,
for the way to the molecule you generate.
Now we're going to be talking
about oxidation of aldehydes
and alcohol's we have
talked about some of them already, but
it's nice to do those in a green way too.
And in fact, we already talked about
some, uh, such a reaction last semester.
It was one of the first
oxidations of, of, uh, of, uh,
of an Aldehyde that was studied,
which was the oil of bitter almonds.
You remember what was
special about this sample
when you turned it over?
It turned out that this Aldehyde
was in fact mostly solid.
It had converted spontaneously to, to, uh,
to benzoic acid without adding any of,
uh,
chromium manganese or anything like that.
You got benzoic acid just
by reacting it with oxygen.
So there could hardly be a
cleaner, greener, uh, uh,
process.
So the air oxidation of Benzaldehyde
is a process that I think we mentioned
before, but I'll talk about it again.
So it's a free radical chain reaction.
So you have some radical, which pulls
the hydrogen away from the Aldehyde,
which generates this ACL radical,
but the ACO,
radical canal attack,
oxygen to form a new bond
and a single bond to oxygen,
which itself is now a radical,
which is the X.
Okay?
So x comes back and takes a hydrogen from
the other and the product then is not
benzoic acid,
but per Roxy benzoic acid.
So that's what you would expect to
get at first. All right. But, uh,
in fact, it might be fun for
you just to, to, uh, review, uh,
free radical chain reactions by re,
by writing this thing in one of those
cyclic diagrams as to what comes in,
where the radicals are, what comes out.
That would be a good exercise, right?
So this is the initial product,
but this itself is an oxidizing agent.
It's got this week oxygen,
oxygen bond, a low Lumo,
which is, uh, uh,
which is a little bit like
using a halogen halogen bond.
So it also is like an alcohol,
so it can form a Hemi Ke Tau
by attacking the carbon eel.
So here's the group that attacked,
here's the new bond and we have, Ooh,
so it's like a heavy key towel, except
it's per Roxy. And now notice it,
it's converted, uh, the, uh,
what would have been an Oah into
an o with alleving group. Okay.
If this had just been a regular old, uh,
hydrate of the Aldehyde, there'd be Ooh,
here. But now we have, oh,
with the leaving group,
so base can pull off the Proton
electrons come in to make a double bond.
These leave,
and now you have benzoic acid and eight,
which is a base that can do
that reaction next time. Right?
So what could be a more
efficient reaction?
All you do is expose Benzaldehyde to
oxygen and it becomes benzoic acid.
So there is a very green
oxidation reaction. Okay.
You can see section 1812
which talks about this. Okay.
But the last year when I was
talking about this subject,
we had a seminar from a professor at
the Vitamin Institute, David Milstein,
who talked about devising
catalysts for greener operations.
And I thought this one was
a very interesting one.
So this is a Ruthie medium catalyst and
it has on carbon monoxide and hydrogen
and then this funny league
and that it's a peer,
a dean of Benzine with the
nitrogen in it with two groups,
Cah do here ch two and it has a nitrogen,
Diane ethyl amine on this end and dye
tee butyl phosphene on the other end.
So it has three things with
unshared, pairs, phosphorous,
nitrogen and nitrogen that can mix with
the orbitals of the ruthenium to make
this complex.
Now I've met,
I've colored two of the hydrogens here,
green because there they can come off,
you can lose age to having lost those
two hydrogens notice or you can add h two
and come back again.
Now how does that happen?
Well notice that this,
this stuff here with the nitrogen plus
charge with an extra bond here going to
this kind of a ring is a little bit
reminiscent of what we saw before with Nad
plus Nadh that this is a nuclear fillic
aromatic substitution, the start of it.
So the h minus ads here,
these go onto the nitrogen.
So you have a ring like
that one and h attached,
but the h minus can come off again and
be given to something else. So there are,
this is closely balanced,
right?
This one has the advantage
of being aromatic.
This one has the advantage of having a
new bond and not being charged, right?
So being closely balanced,
it can go back and forth.
So the same way that Nadh in nature
can function as both an oxidizing and a
reducing agent going one way and another,
you could imagine that a thing like
this could go back and forth. So, uh,
lose the h plus and go back as far as,
as far as the stability of this part
of it goes. But there's a problem.
The h could be thought of as h minus
because it's bonded to a metal,
right?
So the electrons are mostly on the more
electronegativity negative hydrogen,
but it can't reach to that position.
So you can't do that kind of thing.
But what it can reach
is the hydrogen here.
If we change the confirmation of
the thing a little bit, right?
So you can imagine that these elect
the hydride attacks this hydrogen,
which loses these electrons
to make that bond.
And that's helped by the fact that these
electrons that get stabilized by moving
onto the positive nitrogen,
right? So this is what a lot,
this type of of effect is what allows us
to go back and forth either direction,
but we're most interested
in the direction going up.
So let's redraw that thing and,
and look at what happens
if there's an alcohol.
So an alcohol comes in and it's unshared
payer makes a bond to the ruthenium,
right? And now it's all plus. Okay? Now,
uh,
we could have the hydride
notice it's h uh, uh,
wait a second. If I don't
right through here, oh no. Uh,
what we're doing is using the
unshared pair of nitrogen.
This is not like hydride I said
the wrong thing. This is a proton.
The electrons are going
away from this hydrogen.
So the Proton is able to go on here,
right?
Degenerate the end plus again.
Okay.
And now notice that the
same time that that, uh,
alcohol that came on had an h had
two H's that I drew explicitly.
The one down here is the one
I'm interested in because
it's near the Ruthie Diem,
right?
And now we can,
if this were oh minus and notice in a
sense it is oh minus because it's bonded
to a metal,
right?
Then the electrons of the old minus these
electrons can make a double bond here
giving hydride a hydride
can attack the ruthenium
like that.
So notice what the product of this
is that we're at the top. We get,
we got a carbonyl group,
right?
And the thing we have at
the bottom is this, right?
Which can start the whole process
over again by giving off h two.
So what is this whole
catalytic cycle accomplished?
It you've brought in an alcohol
and you removed from it.
These two hydrogens as h two.
Okay?
So it's a way of,
so it's an oxidation of the alcohol,
not by bringing in
oxygen and making water,
but by giving off h two.
Okay?
So now you can do another, in this
particular reaction, there's another, uh,
oxidation. It re removing h
two from a different alcohol.
Notice the product is an Aldehyde,
but in water it will form a dial.
So it can be the alcohol that comes in
and you remove another h two from it,
which gives them, uh, uh, uh, uh,
a carboxylic acid plus oxidizing another,
uh,
alcohol, uh, and have CEO coupling.
And you get a,
if I had done this right,
I think I counted wrong here.
I think I wrote this wrong. Uh,
I don't think you oxidize that alcohol,
but at any rate at couples
to give the Esther,
I think that should be two a h
two is there, I'll correct that.
Okay.
But this happens in the presence of this
catalyst with no other op activation.
So what comes in as the alcohol,
what comes out as two moles of
hydrogen and the Ester, right?
A very clean process.
Okay,
so here's a table taken from Milstein
stable from Milstein is paper and you can
see with several different, uh, alcohols,
he was able to get high conversions
higher than 90 up to 99%.
Very high yields of the Ester and
only a little bit of the Aldehyde.
Most of it got oxidized.
Uh,
let's look at the thermo
chemistry of this. And again,
I think that should be two h twos.
So if you look at the heat of formation
of ethanol and the heat of formation of
the Ester,
that's the product from that.
And hydrogen has a free energy of zero.
So the two hydrogens don't count.
But if we add it together,
this reaction is endothermic
by 17 kilocalories per mole.
So it's way up hill.
You'd think the equilibrium
constant would be very unfavorable.
What makes it possible for this to happen?
Catalytically right?
We're not putting in something that's a
strong reagent that makes one of these
very reactive and then it can
react with the other things.
We're just putting the alcohol in and
to have the alcohol come in and Esther
come out and everything stayed the same.
Otherwise,
with the catalyst right there,
you have to go uphill and energy
by 17 kilocalories per mole,
which sounds very tough, but there
are two things that make this uh,
that make this good,
right? You form three, uh,
but you form,
uh,
you start with two molecules and you
form three molecules to h two and the
Ester, again, I counted wrong here. Uh,
so by making more molecules,
you make more entropy available.
And furthermore,
this is especially helped because you
make those two hydrogen gas molecules and
you can remove those from the solution.
So notice how this was done.
It was done in one case under a flow of
our gone to sweep the hydrogen gas out.
And in the other case, the, the Taleo
in solution was refluxed, which again,
take the solvent, pushes the
other gas out. So, uh, so at,
at, at low pressure of hydrogen, it's
possible to do this spontaneously.
So these are, that's an, uh,
an important type of analysis to do on
a catalytic cycle as to whether that
you've proposed as to whether in fact
it could be thermodynamically allowed.
They also were able to
make a means that way.
Starting with alcohol's make
an a mean by reacting with,
with ammonia.
So alcohol plus ammonia,
it gives it a mean and also
incidentally and m mean.
So probably it's the same kind of thing
before the alcohol gets oxidized to an
Aldehyde, but in the presence of
the nitrogen, it forms the amine,
the CN double bond. And
then that can get, uh,
that gets reduced to give the by the
hydrogen that's there in order to give,
give the, uh, uh, mean, but again,
these are very high yield, uh,
reactions
and notice that it says that they're
there too. When you look at, uh,
a synthetic paper and a table in it,
it's important to look at two
different kinds of yields. The yields,
the normal yields given here are analyzed
by gas chromatography to figure out
how much was in there.
But what you're really interested in is
what you can put in a bottle as a pure
form, right? So the yields in parentheses
are isolated products. So sometimes,
sometimes they're very good
compared to the, uh, to the uh, uh,
gas chromatography yield.
But in this particular case,
it's hard to separate and you
only get half as much out, uh,
to sell to your neighbor
as you had analyzed by GC.
So you can also make it means and
amids and so on with these catalysts.
So that's an interesting development
which seems to address if not to solve
perhaps some of these problems that
the pharmaceutical industry identified.
Now we've been talking in these last
examples of reading chemistry about acids
and acid derivative. So let's talk
about them a little more systematically.
First, the acidity of our co
two h have a carboxylic acid.
You remember that the Ph of a normal,
a carboxylic acid is
between four and five.
Like butyric acid is 4.8.
Now let's look at the effect
of putting a chlorine in there.
So if you put the chlorine
it on the terminal carbon,
it hardly changes the PK
at all just by 0.3 units.
If you move it a little bit
closer to the carboxylic acid,
it's 4.1 and a few moves. Move it as
close as possible to the carboxylic acid.
Now it makes a real difference.
2.8 what is it that the,
what is it that the chlorine is doing?
Hell, I like them. So it's electron
withdrawing and how does that help?
It makes the age
and how does it make the age come off?
Why does it reduce the line?
That's great.
You know,
actually I bet that's not true.
I bet it doesn't reduce the bond strength.
The bond strength is the kind of thing
that professor Alison talked about last
time. Breaking a bond to give
two free people laugh already.
Just mentioned his name and they like,
okay,
you break the bottom and you get two
free radicals. I don't know the results,
but my strong suspicion is that
chlorine hardly affects that at all.
What are the effects is dissociation
as an acid. So what is it?
The chlorine is stabilizing.
It affects the
an ion,
right?
So the electron withdrawal by the
chlorine makes the rest of the wall,
the nearby region of the molecule,
a better place to put more electrons as
in the anti on rather than the neutral
molecule. So this inductive
effect of the chlorine works,
but only in the vicinity of the chlorine
at dies away as you get further and
further from the chlorine.
So this,
this is so called inductive effect and
it's not very big if you're far away,
but if you get pretty
close, it can be big. Okay.
Now let's just see this inductive effect.
If it's,
if it could be quantitatively
reasonable, right? If, if the,
if the withdrawal by the chlorine
stabilizes a negative charge by a certain
amount of energy,
then the process becomes,
the equilibrium becomes easier
by that about of energy, right?
And the, uh, and the,
that energy difference,
right, would appear in the exponent of it
for the equilibrium constant. Remember,
10 to the two thirds Delta Age.
So it would make an effect in the x,
a certain energy effected the exponent.
And if you put two of them in,
you'd do make twice that change.
And the exponent, if it were simple.
Okay.
And that means the results would be
multiplicative because when you add things
in an exponent, that means you
multiply the numbers. Okay?
Okay.
So let's look a Siddique acid chloro a
CD acid dye chloro and try chloro a CD
Casad and see whether this inductive
effect of the chlorine is additive in
energy,
therefore multiplicative in,
in equilibrium, constant. Or if you do
the log of the equilibrium constant,
then it would be additive because
it's up in the exponent. Okay?
So notice here is 4.8 the same as here.
Here it's 2.9 same as here.
So it's the same kind of effect.
Okay? But when we put the second,
but let's look at the values here.
Not at the values themselves,
but at the difference.
How much difference did
that first chlorine made?
It made a difference of 1.9 PKA units.
Now if the second one made this, had the
same effect on the energy of an an ion,
that would also be 1.9.
It's actually 1.6 not quite as big.
And, and the third one is hard,
hardly makes any difference at all.
It's only old 0.6. I mean, it's
substantial, but it's, but, but it's, uh,
but it's not anything like the first ones.
And the reason is that once,
once the anti and is already stabilized,
it gets harder and harder to
withdraw a subsequent electrons.
One chlorine withdraws a certain
much certain amount, the next Galore,
he doesn't have as much to withdraw.
So it can't do quite as good a job.
The third one does very much poorer job,
right?
But fluorine is better than chlorine and
try flouro is CD acid is quite a strong
acid.
It's got a negative PKA.
So that's the inductive effect.
And now might, we might wonder,
what is it that makes the carboxylic
acid acidic altogether ignoring these
additional inductive effects? So, uh,
Paul Ravelin from,
uh,
from Swarthmore college published
the paper in the Journal,
the American Chemical Society in 2000
that had an interesting analysis of this.
And I put it on because, uh, uh, because,
uh,
professor Ellison is such a big advocate
of resonance structures as you saw last
time rather than molecular orbital theory.
So this is an interesting analysis
in terms of resonance structures.
Now what he did is do
very good calculations,
but calculations in the gas phase,
right?
Not in a solvent of what the equilibrium
constant should be for what the energy
involved should be in transferring a
proton from an alcohol to a carboxylic
acid,
right?
So you get the anti into the alcohol
and the protonated carboxylic acid,
and now the carboxylic acids are caused
called acids because they give their
protons to basis.
So this reaction lies to the left and to
go to the right is uphill by almost 28
kilocalories per mole in the gas phase.
Okay?
Uh,
now the difference in Pka,
the PK of an alcohol is about 16.
The PK of a carboxylic acid is about five.
So the difference in PKA is
about 11. Right? Therefore,
you would expect the equilibrium constant
at room temperature to be about four
thirds of that. So it should be
about 15 kilocalories per mole,
right? But notice that pks
are defined in water, right?
So it must be that the solvent
makes an enormous effect, right? Uh,
it reduces this to about half of its
value from near close to 30 to 15.
By making it easy,
it makes it easier to go to the right
only 15 kilocalories uphill instead of 30
kilocalories uphill.
Why?
It could be because this one has a
much more concentrated negative charge.
So it gets more effectively solve,
aided by the water compared to this one,
which helps drive the reaction to the
left. But anyhow, that's a secondary, uh,
consideration,
uh,
because we're just looking as rambling
did at the molecules in the gas phase.
Okay. So it's a 28 kilocalories
uphill to do that. Now,
what's the reason? Why does it
want to go that way? Well, we're,
we're tempted to say
resonance. You have, uh,
that's certainly what Ellison
would have said, right?
You have two resonance structures of this,
an ion and only one resonance structure
of that's reasonable for the on the
right.
Okay.
Can you think of any other
reason that it might be good to,
to go to the left? Anything? Uh,
anything else that makes that a better
and I in compared to this anti on other
than residents.
Okay.
Had the ideas this,
these are H's incidentally
c h three y here's h,
c o o minus.
If residents weren't a factor,
would you expect these to be the same?
Would you expect to
equilibrium constant to be one
maybe.
Yeah.
The Pi Star helping,
yeah. Is the molecular orbital way
of saying there's residents, right?
That's what, that's how they do it. So
that, that in fact is the same thing.
But is there anything else that
would tend to make it go that way?
Pardon me? And what, how
would the oxygen health,
so it could be an inductive
effect that notice this oxygen
closer than the chlorine that was making
the difference before the chlorine was
out on the next carbon.
Okay.
So you could also have an
inductive effect due to the oxygen.
Now notice that it's a double bond.
So it's an interesting question whether
you count the oxygen once or counted
twice.
Okay?
So for purposes of this paper,
uh,
Ramblin hypothesize that you
count the oxygen twice. Okay?
So now we have residents and inductive
effects and we can do some numerology
about these, about how important
resonance structures are. Okay?
So notice that this 27.9 kilocalories is
due to loss of resonance and to loss of
two inductive effects for oxygen.
If you're supposed to count
it twice with a double bond.
Now let's look at this one, where we've
put where we, instead of using alcohol,
we use a ketone and a protonated
acid here. So instead of the ad,
and it's protonated now and
now we transfer the proton
from here to the Ketone
Aldehyde. Actually these
are hydrogens, okay?
So we make the protonated
ketone and the carboxylic acid.
Now here,
the reaction lies to the right,
okay? It's exothermic by 6.2
kilocalories from all the gas phase.
Now which side would resonance favor?
Yeah.
Debbie, can you help us out? Can you draw,
would you draw a resonance
structures of this? You could,
you could use the unshared pair on the
Oah and it would be stabilized by the Pi
Star, but that would require
separation of charge.
And Ellison told us we
don't want to do that. Okay.
How about on the left and he
resonance structures there?
Yes.
Speak up positive now.
Now you could draw a double bond deer in
a single bond there and put the charge
on the bottom and you're not separating
charge. You just moving the charge.
So here or you have good residents here.
You don't have on the right,
you don't have reasonable resonance.
Okay?
On this one you had residents on the
left and not on the right. So now,
uh, now the or don't park. In both
cases we had residents on the left.
Okay?
So resonance is going to be,
is going to favor the left and cause
you to go uphill in either case.
Okay.
Now how about the inductive effect?
How about the oxygen? We'll
try somebody else here. Chris,
which side is favored by the
inductive effects? In the top,
the inductive effects favorite,
the left,
because we had two bonds to
oxygen withdrawing electrons
stabilized in the anti
right? Now how about in this
case when we have two bonds here?
Okay,
that's good.
If it stabilizes,
the anti in the argument is
it destabilizes the cat I
and so it's the same deal
except now the,
the uh,
we same residents that would cause
it to go uphill to the right,
but the oxygen now makes it
go down to the left. Okay?
Now how many,
uh,
how many oxygens did we air this time
is just the difference between this.
And this is just this bond,
right?
So it's not a question of counting one
or two and there's only one bond there.
So that's one inductive effect of oxygen.
Now we have two equations in two unknowns.
The effect we have the residents effect,
which is the same direction in both
cases and the, and the inductive effect,
which is in opposite directions and
twice as strong in one case, right?
So if we take, if we take the
difference of these two minus this one,
right?
We get plus 34.1 is three of
the oxygen inductive effects.
So the opposite inductive effect
is 11.4 kilocalories per mole.
And once we have that,
we can plug back in to see how big the uh,
the resonance effect is. It's 4.8. Okay.
And now if we use this
from this point of view,
if we look that in the top case of that
30 kilocalories per mole going uphill,
only five of it was due to resonance by
far and away the dominant effect is the
inductive effect, right? Only
20% of the special acidity,
the carboxylic acid is due to
residents from this viewpoint,
okay? Now you may buy this
resonance argument and you may not,
I'm personally skeptical,
but, but one way or the other,
it would be good to check it.
So Ravelin checked it.
So he did this one with carbonic acid,
the anti enough of carbonic acid,
and now that's plus 37.3.
Now what does it involve?
Here's the anti in which is stabilized
by resonance as this one was,
right?
And there's no resonance involving this
one because it has the hydrogen on it.
Okay. And how about, so it has
resonance the same as the others.
How about inductive effect?
How many ops compared to this?
How many oxygens are stabilizing this?
O minus that?
Count three. If you count double bond
twice, which is the rules he set,
then you have three. Okay, so that's Oh,
inductive times three.
Now let's put that together.
So we have oh inductive times three,
that's a 34.2 and the
resonance is 4.8 is 39
not bad. Okay, so we can
try another one. Okay.
So here we do the, the, the analog
of what we did here, put a proton on.
And now, uh, we have, uh,
no resonance on the right.
We have residents on the left.
How many resonance structures
in addition to the original structure,
Chris,
you can draw the double bond here.
That's what we did in that case,
which could also draw the
double bond over here, right?
So there should be residents
times two, right? And that should,
that should favor the left,
make it uphill. Right?
But also you're going to have oxygen's
destabilizing this cat I and two oxygens
d stabilizing that cat island.
Right? And if you put those together,
it's minus 13.2 and observed as 11.
So they thought that is so
there are people who think this,
right?
Uh,
I personally don't like this kind of
argument so much because I don't think it
comes down to really the
physics of the thing.
It comes to count whether you count a
double bond to bonds and things like that,
which uh,
it works out.
So there are people who talk about
this thing and from that point of view,
resonance isn't as important to making
acids acidic as inductive effect is.
So the inductive effect
is certainly important.
Now making acids by oxidation
and reduction. No, we've
talked about these things.
A oxidizing and alcohol
with chromium oxidizing.
And remember on the way
you get an Aldehyde,
so you can also oxidize aldehydes
and you could do it with chromium.
I put potassium purveying bag aid in here.
We also talked about oxidized in double
bonds with ozone and then hydrogen
peroxide to get a carboxylic acids.
There's one different type of oxidation
that we haven't talked about yet,
which is mentioned in the, in the
Jones textbook here, uh, which is,
uh,
Al Keel groups attached to a benzene
ring can be oxidized by permanganate at a
hundred degrees to make
carboxylic acids as well.
Now you can also make a
carboxylic acids by reduction.
You start with,
of course this,
the carbon and a carboxylic acid
is pretty much oxidized, right?
But there are more
oxidized things like CO2.
So if you had CO2,
what would you react that with in order
to form a carbon carbon bond to make the
carboxylic acid?
What kind of reagents?
What would attack the carbon of CO2?
Hi.
Hi Homo or low Lenovo.
Yeah.
What would make CO2 double bond?
Double Bond. What would make it react?
Suppose it were just a single double bond.
What makes it react?
The Pi Star, right? Alo Lumo
so you want a high Hobo,
just like the things we talked about
with alcohols, right where you can,
you can have a ketone reacted with r
minus reacted with h minus to go on.
And then in this case,
that would be a reduction of the carb
central carbon and would form a carboxylic
acid. So you could do that
kind of thing too. Oh,
you can also react a carboxylic acids
with al kill lithium or hydride cotton
pounds.
So for example,
you can react a generic carboxylic
acid here with Al Kewill lithium.
What do you think the product is?
Yeah.
What would the AR, ar, ar Alfio
lithium is like our minus, right?
It's a high homo on the
are the are lithium bond.
So what will it attack
Mary,
in addition to what? Carbon to the carbon
deal. Right? That's what, that's what I,
that's what I was trying
to trick you into.
Say in fact it reacts in another way.
Can you think of any other,
what else can it,
what else does a high homo do
besides make something a nucleophile?
It makes it a base.
Here we have an asset. So in fact, the
easy thing to react with is the proton.
That's easier to access than the
carbon eel. Whoops, I'm sorry.
I've talked too long. Uh,
thanks for your patience.